На вигляд - звичайна валіза, а всередині -
мобільний вівтар.
- Раніше тут зберігалося приладдя для архієреїв, свічки.
Я подивився у владики й думаю: дуже гарний
чемоданчик буде нам для служби.
А ця зала, ніби конструктор "Лего", перевтілюється
в місце для проведення служби.
Такий собі імпровізований храм ПЦУ.
- Тут усе швидко робиться. Штори розсунули,
тюль зняли, скатертину купили, ікони в нас всі необхідні є.
До будинку Галини Карпюк у селі Морозівка
Київської області отець Олексій приїжджає
щонеділі. Рік тому, коли Україна отримала томос,
місцева парафія УПЦ Московського патріархату
була однією з перших, хто приєднався до нової
Православної церкви України
разом зі своїм священником,
але напередодні президентських виборів
священник раптово вирішив попросити покаяння
і повернутися в Московський патріархат.
Кілька сотень селян, які поставили свої підписи
під заявою про перехід до ПЦУ, опинилися
в прямому сенсі за парканом церкви.
Галині Карпюк досі дуже прикро.
- Я просто цим людям не могла не надати прихистку,
коли почалися холоди, дощі. Стояти там на вулиці,
під тином такої великої церкви, яка будувалася
всім селом… У мене тут 50 метрів. Я сказала:
йдіть до хати. Не треба так. Це ж літні люди.
Виходить, замість об'єднання томос розколов
Морозівку на два табори. Прихильники
Московського патріархату категорично відкидають
ідею, щоб у храмі по черзі відправляли службу Божу
різні парафії.
- Ото стара церква, яка була раніше.
Нехай там собі займаються… Ну, ви зрозуміли.
Прихильники ПЦУ не можуть зрозуміти
такого ворожого ставлення до себе.
Декого це доводить до сліз. Як-от мати загиблого
під Донецьком воїна АТО, яка досі не може забути,
як у Московському патріархаті їй відмовили
провести панахиду на могилі сина.
- Він врятував хлопців. А мені кажуть, що він братовбивця.
Він прийняв весь вогонь на себе.
Врятував дітей.
Отець Олексій ще рік тому теж був служителем
УПЦ Московського патріархату в сусідньому селі.
Він став одним із перших священників МП,
хто вирішив перейти до ПЦУ. На його думку,
пристрасті в Морозівці могли би вщухнути,
якби парафія ПЦУ нарешті отримала
офіційний статус і віряни могли б через суд
спробувати відстояти своє право користуватися храмом.
Документи на реєстрацію парафія вже подала
й кілька місяців безрезультатно чекає на реєстрацію.
- Час трохи втрачений.
Треба було швидкими кроками йти до цього.
Все було в наших руках, так скажемо.
Церковна влада…. ну, розумієте, ті люди,
вони переходили з надією, що
піде великий розвиток. А поки що ми стоїмо на одному місці.
Як стверджує ПЦУ, за рік після створення до її лав
вирішили приєднатися близько 500 парафій
Московського патріархату. Утім, на Київщині,
приміром, жодна з цих парафій досі
так і не отримала документи про реєстрацію.
Колишній митрополит Московського патріархату,
а нині митрополит Переяславсько-Вишневської
єпархії ПЦУ, Олександр Драбинко вважає, що
процес переходу до ПЦУ наразі більше нагадує
декларацію про наміри, оскільки не працюють
закони, які були ухвалені задля створення ПЦУ.
- Прибрати олігархічний і фінансовий вплив
і зайнятися виконанням законодавства.
У нас є закони, згідно з якими громада може
самовизначатися. Але коли громада збирається,
аби провести збори й самовизначитися,
до якої конфесії їй належати, тоді в нас місцеві
благочинні або архієрей збирає автобус
зі всього району або з області,
приїжджають і починають психологічний
та інколи фізичний тиск, закриваючись у церкві,
аби не дати можливості самовизначитися громаді.
Парафіяни ПЦУ в Морозівці попри всі негаразди
готові терпіти, аби зберегти головний,
на їхній погляд, результат церковної реформи:
здобуття Україною незалежної від Москви
православної церкви, яка поволі здобуває
і міжнародне визнання. Віряни бачать для себе
в ПЦУ багато переваг.
- Україна зовсім новою стає і церква повинна бути
нашою, новою. Такою, як вона починалася колись.
- Росія пішла туди, а ми пішли в Україну.
От ми з Україною і живемо.
- Українська молитва дуже доступна.
Все розумієш, що читається,
що кажуть, все це доступно.
- Найбільш позитивний результат - те, що
дуже багато гарних громадян об’єдналися.
Дякуючи новій церкві, ці люди отримали
дуже гарних священиків. Дуже багато людей просто
зневірилися і в самому храмі, і в самому сані
священика, і просто не ходили в церкву.
Отець Олексій теж не втрачає оптимізму.
Для нього нова українська церква - це молода
сучасна церква із сучасними підходами,
де більше не засуджують жінок за відсутність хусток
у храмі. Де дозволяється сміятися.
Де читають проповіді на близькі людям
актуальні теми - про щеплення, біометричні паспорти,
проблеми екології. Де церква активна
навіть у соцмережах, аби приваблювати
більше молоді. І де не обов’язково проводити
служби Божі виключно в храмі.
Це можна робити скрізь, навіть на природі.
- Чому паритися в храмі?
Приходять маленькі дітки, приходять літні люди.
Якісь подушки розклали, щось поклали на зеленій травичці.
Хтось сів, хтось грається з діточок. Ми відслужили,
поспілкувалися, посміялися,
як християни нормальні, і пішли.
Це нонсенс в 21 сторіччі.
І слава Богу, що ми до цього прийшли.
Ми все пережили. Дай Бог нам далі
від цього не відмовлятися.
Бо це круто - правити такі літургії.
Парафіяни в захваті від нових підходів.
Вони вже запланували різдвяну службу в місцевому кафе,
бо розмістити всіх у будинку Галини Карпюк неможливо.
Парафіяни ПЦУ впевнені, що незабаром отримають
документи про реєстрацію і вже в офіційному
статусі в 2020-му почнуть будувати собі свій храм.